today on the mat wall show the death
cult known as the fat acceptance
movement has claimed another victim and
she happens to have been one of its more
visible Advocates also it's always been
bad news when Democrats and Republicans
agree on something which is evidenced by
the disastrous bipartisan spending Bill
researchers supposedly discover a new
cure for long covid but what the hell is
long covet is it anything and Media
Matters names their top misinformers of
the year I could not be more honored to
have made the list all of that and more
today on the Matt Walsh show
foreign
[Music]
well if you're someone who has always
wanted to read and understand the Bible
but you're not sure where to start then
check out the Bible in a year podcast
from Ascension press the Bible in a year
podcast is currently the most popular
religion podcast in the US millions of
people have listened to it and twice
it's hit the number one spot on Apple
podcast in the Bible in a year father
Mike Schmitz reads the entire Bible in
365 daily episodes providing helpful
commentary reflection and prayer along
the way what better way to start the new
year you can find the Bible in a year
podcast with father Mike Schmitz for
free and your favorite podcast app or on
YouTube plus you follow along with a
special reading plan to help you better
understand the story unlike any other
Bible podcast Bible in a year follows a
special reading plan that organizes the
books of the Bible in a way that helps
listeners understand the story so get
this reading plan at ascensionpress.com
Walsh if you want to start reading and
more importantly understanding the Bible
this year go to ascensionpress.com Walsh
to download the reading plan for free
it's ascensionpress.com Walsh to
download the reading plan for free
you may not be familiar with the name
Jamie Lopez I certainly wasn't until
this week when she died but her death is
worth discussing whether you'd heard of
her or not before uh before now Lopez
was the founder of a well-known beauty
salon called baby doll Beauty Couture
and she was the star of a reality show
called super size salon now as the title
of the show indicates the salon was
focused on providing services to obese
people proudly billing itself as the
world's first plus-sized Salon Lopez
herself was a plus size model and as
media reports about her death have
characterized her she was a quote Fierce
advocate of fat acceptance and body
positivity her show and her public brand
centered around the basic message that
everyone is beautiful no matter their
size and we should accept and celebrate
all body types
she was only 37 when she died this week
they've not released a confirmed cause
of death but the Daily Mail and other
outlets report that she was suffering
from heart complications among other
potential
maladies now
there's a reason why I bring this all up
but before I flesh that out it may be
enlightening to watch A Brief sneak peek
of the super-sized Salon show which was
posted on WE TV's YouTube channel a few
months ago to promote the show and the
problems we're going to talk about are
all Illustrated I think very explicitly
in this clip and here it is
I just love beautiful things it's just a
part of me I've been doing makeup since
I was 13 years old I just have always
just loved making women feel beautiful
oh my God
I am a social media influencer in the
plus size community
I Fest every single day Jamie in the big
girl Community is like an icon she's
very beautiful confident she is really a
goat Jamie's just a fabulous the Amazon
she loves to just see people happy
you're gorgeous
I am the owner and Creator and the hbic
of baby doll Beauty Couture welcome to
Bay
[Music]
my dream was to create the first ever
all-inclusive salon by plus size girls
for plus-sized girls you're in good
hands society makes you hate yourself if
you don't look a certain way and I am
damn determined to change that baby doll
is about embracing who you are yes girl
yes you might have fat ass people come
to your salon but you don't have a plus
size Salon when cheers for big asses
like ours all this
it's for all it is
so it's a message that's a sermon that
we hear all the time in our culture we
should not make obese people feel bad
about themselves everyone is beautiful
fat is beautiful everyone should be
accepted all weights all sizes
um indeed fatness is now its very own
identity group there is as we heard in
the clip there a community a Sisterhood
of fat women and this community deserves
to be included and tolerated
even as they kill themselves in front of
us
now the tragic reality here is that
Jamie Lopez was apparently trying to
lose weight towards the end of her life
and her heavy issue had reached 846
pounds
and found herself uh unable she was bed
bound she was unable to support her own
weight enough to move around without
assistance and and she had apparently
dropped a significant amount of weight I
think maybe like half her body weight
but was still you know 400 pounds
extremely morbidly obese and it would
seem
the damage had been done because our
bodies are not meant to carry around
that kind of weight our bones our
internal organs our you know our hearts
none of it was built to support hundreds
of pounds of excess fat
that's why morbid obesity will kill you
it's not an if here there's no if it's
not like a maybe that the only thing
that will stop a morbidly obese person
from dying of their obesity
is if they die from something else first
or if they lose the weight before the
clock Runs Out
neither those two things happen and they
will die of obesity will 100 of the time
um Jamie Lopez was one of thousands upon
thousands of obese people every year who
perish from the condition the clock runs
out something like a quarter of a
million Americans die from obesity
related causes every year which makes up
ten percent of all obesity related
deaths globally in spite of the fact
that the US only comprises four percent
of the global population
now Lopez may have tried to lose weight
at the end but she was a part of and a
victim of also a movement
that tells obese people that they don't
need to lose weight unless they want to
like if you want to then go ahead but
but you don't need to
the fat acceptance movement body
positivity has killed countless people
in this country and now it's killed one
of its more prominent advocates
and that's the point we should be
focusing on this is not about exploiting
certainly not about making light of a
woman's tragic death it's about
confronting the fact that the fat
acceptance Movement typified by nearly
everything you heard in that promotional
clip is a suicidal ideology I mean it is
a death cult fat acceptance is a death
cult it's one of the most dangerous
ideas in the world and that's not an
exaggeration
at a time when we're so focused on the
alleged harms inflicted by you know
quote-unquote misinformation
it's probably time that we start
thinking about the misinformation that
tells people like Jamie Lopez and so
many others that morbid suicidal
self-destructive obesity is something to
be celebrated
that it's beautiful
Lopez will not be the only body
positivity influencer to die in early
death they will almost all suffer the
same fate fat acceptance became a
mainstream Phenomenon with its own slate
of Advocates and stars and influencers
in just the past 10 years or so we're
reaching the point now where we might
expect to start seeing many of them
succumb to their obesity
but then again if 280 000 obesity
related deaths every single year isn't
enough for a wake-up call I imagine that
every single quote fat acceptance
celebrity could die
and that wouldn't be enough either
still whether people want to hear it or
not we need to start speaking some hard
truths truths truth such as this
obesity
is not beautiful
it is it is not beautiful for the same
reason that we don't call alcoholism
beautiful or anorexia beautiful if
somebody engages in self-harm and cuts
themselves we don't say that the scars
are beautiful if a crazy guy
self-immolates we don't stand around the
fire talking about how pretty the flame
is
it's not because we hate the alcoholic
or we hate the anorexic or we hate the
cutter or we hate the self-immolator
exactly the opposite we love them and
therefore we hate what is destroying
them you should hate the things
that destroy
or threaten to destroy the people that
you love
including obesity
now there some people will undoubtedly
criticize me for talking about this
right now only a couple days after the
woman died they'll say that it's
exploitative disrespectful
and yet if she was a member of the
alcoholism is beautiful movement and
then died of liver disease stemming from
alcohol consumption we would all agree
that it would be absurd to not talk
about the connection what else are you
going to talk about to ignore it would
be ludicrous even Reckless
the same applies here
now is not only an acceptable time but
the most important time to point out
that there is nothing beautiful about
self-destruction
there's nothing beautiful about an early
grave these are ugly horrid things they
are brutal and grotesque
fat acceptance as a movement as an
ideology is brutal and grotesque it is a
celebration of death
we shouldn't just oppose it and disagree
with it we should hate it we should hate
it for the deadly Sinister propaganda
that it is
now I think the problem
in part at least
is that we've bought into this this lie
that lifestyles are sacrosanct
right however pers however a person
chooses to live is automatically above
reproach simply because they're living
that way
to criticize a lifestyle
such as a lifestyle of overeating
gluttony lethargy laziness that is to
suggest that a person should live
differently from how they're currently
living but that's the ultimate heresy in
our culture
because for us the the only thing you
are meant to say or that you can say
about a person's lifestyle is that it's
courageous and inspirational
right we're at a point now where all
lifestyles are Courageous by default
simply to live however you feel like
living is an act of Courage
whereas to live differently from how you
feel like living to make purposeful
changes with the intention of becoming a
different sort of person is somehow an
act of
self-betrayal
and to encourage others to live
differently is bigotry Prejudice hatred
but this is all nonsense
and it is getting people killed
lots of people every single day
when will enough be enough that's the
question
now let's get to our five headlines
you know with everything going on in the
world right now you could really use a
good night's sleep that's why you need
to check out Helix mattress I've had my
Helix for years now and I absolutely
love it I sleep like a baby even in the
midst of what's arguably my busiest
season I'll probably change once the
twins arrive but for now I am sleeping
like a baby until we have babies a
mattress should never be a one size
fits-all solution because why should you
have to compromise on Comfort Helix has
a sleep quiz that matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you because why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else go
to helixsleep.com Walsh take their
two-minute sleep quiz and find the
purchase perfect mattress for your body
type and your sleep type your mattress
will come right to your door for free
plus Helix has a 10-year warranty and
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free leave and pick it up for you
if you don't love it but you will I
guarantee so for a limited time Helix is
offering up to 350 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners this is an amazing offer take
advantage of it at helixsleep.com Walsh
with Helix better sleep starts now
it's from the daily wire lawmakers on
Capitol Hill touted a 1.7 trillion
dollar funding package on Tuesday with
both Democrats and Republicans claiming
victories and it's designed to avert a
government shutdown when the current
funding expires at midnight on Friday
the text of the legislation is uh some 4
000 pages long leaving very little hope
for lawmakers even with the help of AIDS
to get through the text prior to voting
on the massive massive package and
according to the Heritage Foundation the
Omnibus Bill they may not have the time
to read is packed with woke pet projects
among them are a number of lgbtq
projects from Pride centers to museums
and anti-racism initiatives according to
a thread shared on Twitter on Tuesday
this is the game of course you know as
always is to have these bills that are
thousands of thousands pages long that
nobody could hope to read through and
then
right before it's passed and even after
it's passed I mean infamously of course
it was Nancy Pelosi who said we have to
pass it to find out what's in it and
that that has been
you know that I believe the time she was
talking about Obamacare but that's
that's that's how it works with all
legislation now you just pass it you get
the gist of it and then you pass it and
uh and then later on you find what's in
it
and there's always this false sense of
urgency it's like why why can't we take
a little bit of time there's no reason
why any bill needs to be 4 000 pages
long to begin with
there's no reason why that should be the
case you only do that because you're
trying to sneak through all these kinds
of things you don't you don't want
people to know about
um
but if it is four thousand Pages a week
why can't we take some time
and and look at it first
there's always this false sense of
urgency
the Congress they sit around doing
almost nothing for most of the year and
then out of nowhere we got to pass this
thing right now right now where
everything we're all gonna die
in this case they say well I gotta pass
because we've got to go of course we
have to avert the government shutdown
and what exactly is the problem if the
government shuts down for a bit
we've been through that before promised
uh catastrophic
you know consequences and they never
materialize anyway the thread began with
a headline in all capital letters woke
priorities in the Omnibus
says here are just a few a few earmarks
AKA your taxpayer dollars set aside for
special interests or projects we found
in the
1455 page spending bill that are um
that are funding the left's extreme
agenda using your money at Red in
addendum to the letter later noted that
the number of pages had been a typo at
the actual size of the bill was much
larger it was actually 4 155 pages
um anyway it says so just a few examples
um 1.2 million dollars for lgbtqi plus
Pride centers
1.2 million for services for DACA
recipients AKA helping illegal aliens
with taxpayer funds
uh
477 000 for the equity Institute in
Rhode Island to indoctrinate teachers
with anti-racism virtual labs
more projects were listed in the
following tweets including
one million dollars for Zora's house in
Ohio a co-working and community space
for women and gender expansive people of
color
well that's good
you know what all this other stuff I'm
not really on board for but I was I had
I just think about this the other day in
fact I was wondering I was talking to
somebody about it and I was um and I was
concerned about the fact that gender
expansive people of color in Ohio don't
have
um enough co-working spaces available to
them I was really worried about to put a
million dollars in that that's a very
good thing
um three million dollars for the
American lgbtq plus Museum in New York
City 3.6 million for a Michelle Obama
Trail in Georgia
New York state capital set to receive
three quarters of a million dollars for
LGBT and gender non-conforming housing
Baltimore will rake in a cool two
million dollars for a wax museum
dedicated to African Americans
tentatively named great blacks in wax
great blacks and wax and New York will
get over eight hundred thousand dollars
for an LGBT Center I mean none of this
is actually funny but it's but like what
else are you going to do besides laugh
about it because we have
this is just we have
no control over it
we have no uh no way to stop it because
this is both Republicans and Democrats
who are on board for it
so there's almost no for those of us who
do not agree with 4
000 page
pieces of legislation
that just become this Bonanza for
funding LGBT pet projects all over the
all over the country and all over the
globe those of us who don't agree that
we have almost no representation at all
in Congress
with a few exceptions Rand Paul is one
exception so Rand Paul uh had uh his
reaction to the bill yesterday let's
watch some of this
I brought with me the Omni
4155 pages
when was it produced in the dead of the
night 1 30 in the morning when it was
released
now people argue that it's
conservative's fault it's you don't have
the Christmas spirit somehow you're
holding up government well whose job is
it to produce this the people in charge
of spending the people in charge of both
of the parties when did they know that
this would be necessary well it's in the
law September 30th you got nine months
almost 10 months to produce a plan to
have a spending plan they weren't ready
on September 30th so they voted
themselves 90 more days they weren't
ready last week either so they voted
themselves another week and now we have
it at 1 30 in the morning this morning
but what's the clamor the clamor's
devote vote now let's get it done why
are you standing in the way of spending
well the real question is this what is
more dangerous what is more dangerous to
the country
1.1 trillion dollars in new debt or is
Republican leadership likes to say oh
but it's a win it's a big win we're
getting 45 billion dollars for the
military so which is more important
which threatens the country more are we
at risk for being invaded by a foreign
power if we don't put 45 billion into
the military Are we more at risk by
adding to a 31 trillion dollar debt
I like Grandpa a lot I've always liked
him I mean if he ran in 2024 I would
consider him a really interesting option
um and he's one of the only good ones in
the Senate and he's he's more
libertarian than I am but that's that's
okay he's also he's also consistent
uh much like his his father saying the
same things you know standing for the
same things
um one of the only guys you can trust on
foreign policy he's one of the only
Republicans that will say what he just
said there
which is like questioning at least
questioning the idea no one's saying
that we're not going to fund the
military
but we got to send another 45 billion
dollars there right away or what like
what's going to happen Russia they're
going to invade us really are they going
to be is Russia going to storm the
beaches
as for the bill listen as the senator
points out there is just no interest
among Republican leadership
and among most Rank and file Republicans
to actually cut spending this is one of
the most absurd
you know
one of the most absurd falsehoods that
we hear all the time is that Republicans
are you know the party that stands for
cutting spending they've literally never
done it so just they've never ever done
it so that's a it's a total misnomer
they're not interested in it
very few of them are
because what I mean what does cutting
spending actually mean
first of all it's politically difficult
to do
you know because it means you're going
up to these special interest groups and
so on that have their own little pet
projects and you're saying no we're not
giving you that money that's a
politically difficult thing to do
and it also means less power you know
the more the government spends the more
of our money they spend and the more
power that they have it's the the that's
what the spending really is about
exerting more of their power so to cut
spending is also to cut power and
influence and um what happens big
coincidence
you know so often you have these people
that
run for Congress they want to go to DC
and they say right uh yeah we're going
to reign in the government we're going
to shrink government we're going to
government's too powerful and then they
get into the government and they say
well now that I'm here it's it's a
little bit it's okay now to have all
this power because I'm here
so it is all just a game okay there's a
new HBO documentary about January 6th
that's out and I have no interest in
watching it but I did enjoy this moment
from the director when he was this
director of the documentary and he was
being interviewed on CNN
and this was a lot of fun here it is
the movie's not just about like the the
capital Riot and all that it's also
about like media Echo Chambers
you know what I mean and like the
dangers of the uh 24-hour news cycle and
how I think mainstream media like Fox
and even CNN like competes for views by
running constant 24-hour news Cycles
based upon fear division outrage and
panic probably to like sell ads so it's
not just about the capital right yeah
I'm not I'm not exactly sure first of
all I don't agree with what you're
saying but I'm not exactly sure of how
that played into people going into the
capital uh and rioting on January 6th
um there's nothing fake about CNN oh no
I'm not not saying like fake news I'm
just saying ramping people up and
increasing division during that period
of time
you know Don Lemon was nodding along you
know because when the guy was talking
about cable news he thought he was
talking about Fox you know cable news
and Don lemon's nodding and also CNN
well no no no that's not there's nothing
there's nothing fake about CNN
he doesn't he doesn't see how anything
CNN did prior to January 6 could have
contributed
to January 6th and
well I'm happy to explain that to you
Don
um there's quite a lot actually yes the
the sensationalism for Ratings is a big
part of the story
as the uh guy there
points out
it's this is this is the problem with 24
hour I mean 24-hour news just really
shouldn't exist 24-hour cable news
shouldn't exist because there's just it
like there isn't
there's not urgent news to report 24
hours a day every single day
it's like that nobody needs to know all
of that all the time
and uh what that means they have to
generate interest and of course it all
comes down to ratings and advertising
dollars but but
even before that
what did CNN do
that might have helped contribute to the
events of January 6th those events that
this was not uh this was not this was
not an Insurrection this was not you
know the American way of life hanging in
the balance and the almost overthrew the
government it was not that it was a riot
though
a question about it
so how could CNN have contributed to
Orion well well maybe because they spent
months and months and months prior to
that
defending and encouraging rioting
when it was BLM doing it anyway
maybe that's how CNN and the rest of the
corporate media played a role here
because that wasn't happening in a
vacuum you're sending the message out
that like it's okay to act this way now
it's okay to if something happens and
you don't like it you can do this
you just you could ride and it'll be
fine
and not only can you Riot but you can
even attack government buildings
which as we know the BLM Riders they
actually attacked
it was an actual attack like as in
setting uh police stations on fire
which is something that by the way the
the burning as I've been saying for
years now I'm Not The Only One Of course
uh
but the burning of the police station in
Minneapolis
that that actually was that's like the
real January 6th that that that is
actually the moment that should live in
infamy
that that's that's the moment that we
should be talking about every year when
we get to the anniversary of it
a time in a major American city
the United States of America was which
is supposed to be an advanced civilized
society and here we have a major
American city where a bunch of
animals invaded a police station the
police went running for the lives and
they burned it to the ground
um
but on the on the sensationalism end of
things as well
you know talking about The Sensational
sensationalism and dangers of 24 7 News
uh someone on on Twitter in response to
Don lemon's claims there posted this and
I just thought like it's just a it's a
good good to remember this yeah we
remember we may remember this this uh
episode from semi-recent history
probably the most egregious example of
CNN uh sensationalizing and trying to
keep a story going this of course was
the uh Malaysian flight 370.
and anyway let's just go back and watch
this clip again
what if it was hijacking or terrorism or
mechanical failure or Pilot error but
what if it was something fully that we
don't really understand a lot of people
have been asking about that about black
holes and on and on and on and all of
these conspiracy theories let's look at
this uh Noah says what else can you
think about black hole Bermuda Triangle
and then deji says huh just like the
movie Lost and of course it's also
they're also referencing The Twilight
Zone which has a very similar plot
that's what people are saying I know
it's Preposterous but is it Preposterous
you think Mary
well it is a black holes about you know
a small black hole would suck in our
entire universe so we know it's not that
Bermuda Triangle is often weather and
lost is a TV show so I think I always
like things for which there's data
history crunch the numbers so for me
those aren't there but I think it's
wonderful that the whole world is trying
to help with their theories
that I had forgotten about that
particular moment I remembered CNN with
Malaysian flight 370 while Don Lemon
claims that they never sensationalized
they just would not let this go for
months it was Round the Clock coverage
and uh I had forgotten that he seriously
proposed the possibility that the flight
flew into a black hole now what you said
in response a small black hole would not
suck in the entire universe it would
suck in the entire solar system that it
would do
um so pretty good indication you know
anything's possible I suppose but it's
uh pretty good indication I mean like
maybe
I don't know maybe the black hole sucked
in Malaysian flight 370 and and the and
we were all sucked into black hole too
we were in a black hole right now we
don't even know it I mean like that that
that could happen in a Sci-Fi movie
so they just went crazy with the story
and meanwhile there was never there was
actually never any real big mystery
about the flight because the flight
obviously crashed into the ocean like
that's
they spent they spent months saying what
happened to it where is it it's it's at
the bottom of the ocean they crash in
the ocean that's what happened why did
it crash well that's is a more
interesting question but not one that
necessitated the coverage that CNN gave
it certainly all right here's from uh
story from the Daily Mail
says
two already approved drugs May
effectively treat the millions of
Americans estimated to have long coveted
uh this is Guan
guanfacine I don't know an attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder drug sold
under the name 10x and then another drug
that is abbreviated NAC that I won't
even try to pronounce is a concussion
drug that is branded uh mucomist we're
found to reduce brain fog in two-thirds
of patients
so you have the pharmaceutical companies
now that are on the case trying to come
up with drugs to treat
what they call Long coveted and they've
discovered apparently that what do you
know ADHD drugs may do the job
now I may interest you to know that this
study where they made this discovery
you know you want to just take a guess
on how many uh how big the study was
like how many how many patients were
included in the study well it turns out
12. this was a study on 12 patients
and that is what led them to the
conclusion that you can give ADHD drugs
for quote unquote long coven uh the
article continues doctors at Yale
University believe the combination
protects the brain's prefrontal cortex
from stress and inflammation which can
break down neural connections and cause
the symptoms associated with brain fog
while the study was small only on 12
patients the researchers believe they
have found an effective treatment for
The elusive condition one that is
available at pharmacies right now
well hey they only tried it on 12
patients but that's enough just give it
to you know you tried it out on 12. uh
it seemed to maybe work on a few of them
so let's give it to millions of people
why not
the Centers for Disease Control
prevention report that around eight
percent of Americans are suffering long
covid and More Than 3 500 have died as a
result
okay
you know in a certain way this actually
makes sense because ADHD
is about as real as long coveted so
of course you would treat them with the
same drug
um
am I saying that long-covered doesn't
exist at all
uh
what I'm skeptical about it but it's I
feel the same way about as I do about
ADHD actually so actually again it does
make sense that they're using the same
drug ADHD
I mean are there people
who we have the category of ADHD
and are there people who fall into that
category
sure
but the problem is that it's it's such a
vague
all-encompassing concept
that there's no way really to Define it
so what is long coven I looked up uh the
official symptoms as they're listed on
the CDC website for what what qualifies
as long cover remember they said eight
percent of Americans have long covered
what does that mean exactly
um
so here's a list of symptoms
tiredness or fatigue symptoms that get
worse after physical or mental effort
fever
difficulty breathing or shortness of
breath cough chest pain
fast beating or pounding heart
difficulty thinking
headache sleep problems dizziness when
you stand up pins and needles feelings
change in smell or taste depression
anxiety
diarrhea stomach pain
joint or muscle pain rash changes in
menstrual cycles
so all of those they are qual they are
quantifying as symptoms of long covet
so that's another way of saying that
like if you have covid
anything that happens to you
physiologically after covid could
qualify as long coveted
so anyone could have it
and that's particularly the case for
these kinds of quote unquote symptoms
that are impossible to Define like
anyone can convince themselves that they
have some of this be difficult to
convince yourself you have a fever you
either have that or you don't
but
brain fog
that's if if you want to convince
yourself you have brain fog you can
brain fog is something that everybody
experiences whatever that means exactly
is impossible to Define but it's
something that whatever it means people
experience it probably every day
I wake up every morning I have brain fog
that's been the case in my entire life
have I always had long covet
difficulty concentrating
has have you ever gone through have you
gone through a day in your life
when at least for a period of that day
you didn't have difficulty concentrating
have you have you ever in your life
experienced one full day where you were
able to concentrate perfectly without
any difficulty have you ever experienced
that in your life
and of course depression anxiety I mean
this is what the pharmaceutical company
companies do
This Is How They this is bread and
butter for them
when they can vaguely diagnose and
prescribe treatments for
um
symptoms that are incredibly ambiguous
and that literally anyone could have
and it's uh it's the same thing that
they've been doing in the in the you
know psychiatric world for a long time
and now this is what's happening with
covet as well
all right I was pretty honored by this I
have to say
um Media Matters
list the uh top 10 misinformers in 2022.
well not exactly these are these are
Tucker Carlson's go-to misinformers in
2022.
the top 10 individuals this is a Media
Matters over the past year Fox News is
Tucker Carlson who is being named Media
Matters misinformer of the Year
leveraged his platform to amplify the
reach of these 10 individuals as they
spread misinformation they push topics
including bigotry against immigrants in
the lgbtq community misinformation about
covid-19 the war in Ukraine climate
change and general right-wing grievances
so
Tucker Carlson did get the title of
misinformer of the year uh they didn't
even have like any they didn't even list
any runners up I I you know I knew I
wasn't gonna
I probably was you know competing
against Tucker Carlson it was going to
be a tough competition I'm a little bit
disappointed I mean given the fact that
me I do have my own section on the site
that they list on Google so I you know
I'd like to know how many votes I got at
least
But ultimately they gave it to uh to
Tucker Carlson although I was listed as
one of his top misinformers so uh I feel
pretty good about that they listed his
top misinformers Jason rantz Glenn
Greenwald Candace Owens Tulsi gabbard
who's that lives a tick tock Stephen
Miller Alex Berenson Douglas McGregor
and then also Matt Walsh says the daily
wire self-described Theocratic fascists
and anti-trans extremist Matt Walsh was
a frequent guest guest on Tucker Carlson
type walshow has helped lead a
right-wing campaign of harassment
against Children's Hospitals providing
life-saving gender affirming care to
trans youth that was previously
slandered lgbtq people as groomers was
on the show 12 times
and of course the right wing campaign of
harassment against children's hospitals
that entire campaign consisted of
me and not just me along with lives of
tick tock and Christopher and others
simply pointing out that here hey look
guys look at what these hospitals are
doing
that's that's what harassment is
and this is yet another article you
could read the entire thing and and you
you see lots of people
being labeled misinformer
lots of claims that are labeled
misinformation
and yet they never even tried to explain
how or why we're wrong
like what did we say that was wrong
exactly
what claims do we make about hospitals
that was incorrect
but we know of course that on the left
misinformation is uh it's not wrong
information or faulty information it's
simply information that they find
inconvenient that's what it means all
right let's get now to the comment
section
[Applause]
who's the blame
it's a sweet baby gang
I don't mean to brag by the way but I am
feeling pretty good today uh feeling a
little bit accomplished I I took all
four of my kids out to eat at a sit-down
restaurant last night with two nights
ago actually uh by myself so just me and
the four kids I decided to do this
you know because I've been traveling a
lot over the last few months lots of
traveling it's been hard on the kids
part of my wife so it's like give her a
break take the kids out spend some
quality time and uh so I would take them
all out to eat by myself you know and
this is parenting difficulty level set
to expert
maybe well not quite because expert
level would be buy yourself four kids
and then you go to the kind of
restaurant that doesn't even have a kids
menu right that's that that's not even
expert level that's suicide mission
that's a Kamikaze mission go into like a
nice quiet place with four kids just you
um Kamikaze Mission and the casualties
will be all of the nice people and the
other patrons whose date nights you ruin
so I wouldn't do that instead well I
made it easier on myself and we went to
a Texas Roadhouse and Texas Roadhouse is
great because it's loud it's cheap it's
greasy you know it's not very clean
let's be honest they used to you know
remember Texas Roadhouse they used to
give you I don't think I haven't been to
one in a while that does this but they
used to give you
buckets of peanuts at this place and you
would just you you just Chuck the peanut
shells on the ground
and there's peanut shells all over the
place and they stopped doing that um
when the peanut allergy issue finally
caught up with them I don't know how
they got away with it for so long it's
like 10 years after they banned peanut
butter jelly sandwiches and in uh School
cafeterias
uh Texas Roadhouse was still decorating
their restaurant in peanut shell
confetti so they don't do that anymore
but there still is all other you know
the people throw everything else on the
floor at Texas Roadhouse napkins dirty
diapers just like buckets of barbecue
sauce it's great perfect for a night out
with the kids and uh it went very well
and it was one of those
parenting All-Star moments where you get
the compliment from the old lady there
was an old lady was sitting next to us
she got up to leave and she leaned in
and said your kids are so well behaved
and sweet
and I said to them good job you fooled
her kids just one brief hiccup I had my
face buried in my country fried chicken
with gravy because I was doing low
calorie option as always wasn't playing
close close attention
look over and my three-year-old had
crawled under the table of the Texas
Roadhouse and was sitting on the ground
at the Texas Roadhouse like the ground
that probably hasn't been cleaned since
like the Bush Administration and she's
sitting there
pulled her back up I she may have eaten
something off the floor I didn't want to
ask I didn't want to know this is one of
those it's better not to know situations
but other than that
it was a good experience all right
Gabe Smith says I think calling a 12 12
year old a cadult is a purposeful
Sinister ploy to make the sexualization
of 12 to 13 year olds more acceptable
um yeah I was disturbed by that as well
as we were talking about the so-called
cadults yesterday and
they label that 12 12 plus is a kidult
but as I said yesterday it's like if
you're 12 you're not a kidult or an
adult you're just a kid 12 year old
playing with toys not only fine but I
consider that that's a positive sign if
like a 12 year old's still playing with
something like Legos
because the other option is what the 12
year old's on the screens all the time
you know it's it's that that would tell
me that this is a child that still has
some innocence and some you know
childlike wonder about them and I
consider that a good thing
um adults buying toys is a different
appeal entirely
uh
Paige says Matt is 100 correct growing
up my family never ate at the dinner
table we all ate different things at
different times I watched TV more than I
went outside I first got a device with
the internet when I was seven years old
my most cherished memories of my
childhood are from my grandparents house
when I would uh go to see them and all
my aunts and uncles and cousins but
after they moved away my parents got
divorced I spent every uh even more time
staring at screens eating alone I feel
very little Nostalgia for my childhood
all the toys and movies and TV shows
aren't a replacement for family I think
this kidult trend is very disturbing
and this is the story that uh so many
people in my generation this is your
generation too Millennials this is this
is how they grew up
uh just staring at screens if you think
about like that was the case in the 90s
how much more is it the case for kids
these days
um
another comment says I'm always
flabbergasted
by how how many adults without kids
flood Disneyland and Legoland May making
it an unpleasant experience for those of
us who bring our kids to these
playgrounds and I will
I will never understand that
like it's not only of course immature to
go just as an adult to a place like
Disney World
but also why would you want to if you're
if you're you know like if you don't
have any kids and you want to go with
your wife or someone to to a vacation
somewhere
without kids you could go anywhere you
want
and if you've got the money to go to
Disney World it means you got some money
to spend on the vacation so you got you
have money to spend on a vacation
you don't have kids that you need to
worry about
you've got some time off you can go
anywhere and you decide to wait in lines
at Disney World
doesn't make any sense to me
uh Door Mission says I'm 40 fully
employed happily married have a son I
still collect toys 70s to 90s mainly
it's a hobby of mine plenty of people
collect things that make them happy and
I see nothing wrong with that we're not
hurting anyone and it's one of the many
things my son and I Bond over I love
introducing him to toys and cartoons I
grew up with and luckily I still have a
lot of the toys I grew up with that I
get to share with him yeah a lot of
comments like this people claiming that
they're you know that they are an
exception to what I said about adults
buying toys for themselves and these
responses always frustrate me because
look if you know yourself to be an
exception then fine then you are is it
that there's nothing to worry about I
guess I'm not talking about you what I
said doesn't apply to you that's fine
you know I never said that it applies to
absolutely everyone in the world in fact
I specifically said that if we're
talking about fully competent adults who
are contributing to society and they
have families and they have
responsibilities and they're
well-rounded mature intelligent people
and they also happen to have like a toy
collection
that's not my thing but then it's it's
more of just a it's a quirk or an
eccentricity and if that's your thing
then fine whatever
but the point is that the nine billion
dollars adults spend on toys in a given
year for themselves
that's not all or mostly being driven by
Collectibles okay these are not mostly
people buying Collectibles and the
greater point
is that we do have a major problem of
adults Stuck In Perpetual adolescence
refusing grow up refusing to accept
responsibility
this is not really deniable
I don't think he would deny it we
obviously have that problem in our
culture
and the toy thing is a symptom of that
and I think contributes to that
accepting cases when it doesn't
so that's how you break it down
our small But Mighty team in South
Florida is growing and we're in need of
a new associate producer to make it even
muddier the AP will assist and support
our show producers with General
oversight of show production technical
production skills are a must for this
role as well candidates who have strong
experience with operating cameras
microphones and other audio equipment
are preferred additionally you'll be
responsible for tasks such as helping to
schedule and set up various shows
assisting and coordinating and producing
special show segments prepping material
for guest interviews and more the needs
change every day so you have to be good
at adapting this is an in-office
position in Southern Florida local
candidates are strongly preferred but
we're open to considering exceptional
candidates who are eager to relocate to
South Florida if this sounds like you go
to dailywire.com Walsh and click careers
for more info and also to apply now
let's get to our daily cancellation
foreign
the Avatar sequel Avatar 2 the way of
water was released this past weekend 13
years after the original came out 12 and
a half years after everyone forgot that
the original ever existed it was a brief
moment in time when millions of people
were somehow duped into believing that
Avatar was a good film but the fever
broke rather suddenly most of those who
had fallen under its spell quickly
realized the whole thing was just Fern
Gully as reimagined by the Blue Man
Group not exactly a plot twist therefore
to tell you that the sequel fizzled at
the box office on its first weekend of
release it fizzled with 134 million
dollars over the weekend
to be precise which seems like a lot of
money to qualify as a flop Until you
realize that they spent a billion
dollars making this thing and Port
hundreds of millions into marketing so
that anything less than a historic box
office Hall would be a disappointment
and in this case the movie fell under
even the most modest projections
now I for one am quite pleased with with
this result um I like it when bad movies
perform poorly and this is a bad movie
it may have impressive special effects
but then there really isn't anything
that is actually impressive about
special effects anymore
I'll never understand people these days
who are impressed like well a great
special effects so what if you have a
billion dollars to make a movie we
expect that the CGI will be top of the
line that's like that's just basic level
stuff
what matters is the story and if the
first avatar was a rehash of what a
dozen other films had already done and
done better than Avatar 2 is a rehash of
a rehash
there's nothing new about this kind of
cynical recycling of course but it's
always worse coming from James Cameron
because although
he hasn't had an original idea in like
30 years he still considers himself to
be a genius Storyteller and so both the
first Avatar and this reheated version
are epically absurdly long like this
one's almost three and a half hours long
as Cameron indulges every narcissistic
showy impulse refusing to cut a single
scene or a single line of dialogue
Because he believes that the entire
thing is a Work of Staggering Genius
even though it's literally just
Pocahontas but not as good
on top of that Cameron happens to be one
of the wokest directors currently
working in Hollywood Avatar is of course
an environmentalism allegory about the
Perils of colonialism it's not my
interpretation that's what he says it is
and if the wokeness wasn't clear enough
Cameron's been out on the trail
promoting the film by ranting against
the evils of testosterone as we covered
in a recent daily cancellation he
claimed that testosterone is a poison
that must be purged from the bloodstream
and then on Friday in an interview with
variety he bragged that Avatar is
setting a new standard for female
empowerment because it features a
pregnant female Warrior that's one of
the daily wire test director James
Cameron said in a recent interview that
his upcoming movie Avatar the way of
water is the most empowering movie for
women because one of the characters is a
pregnant Warrior the movie which uh
debuted in theaters across the us on
Friday continues where the first movie
left off uh and in this film one of the
main characters Knight tiri is pregnant
Cameron made the remarks about niteria
during an interview with variety when he
was asked why it was important to have
niteria and another character be
pregnant in the movie
he said quote everybody's always talking
about female empowerment but what is
such a big part of a woman's life that
we as men don't experience and I thought
well if you're really going to go all
the way down the rabbit hole of female
empowerment let's have a Female warrior
who's six months pregnant in battle I
thought let's take the real boundaries
off to me it was the last Bastion That
You Don't See Wonder Woman and Captain
Marvel all these other amazing women
come up but they're not moms and they're
not pregnant while they're fighting evil
yes he's gone down the rabbit hole of
female empowerment
but is this really all the way down the
rabbit hole what about a pregnant female
in a wheelchair in battle
how about a pregnant blind trans woman
with one leg epilepsy and a diagnosed
anxiety disorder in battle
now it's not clear how any of this
actually would be empowering in fact
it's not clear how the exploits of a
fictional character in a CGI Universe
could ever Empower anyone regardless
pregnant or not but this is what
empowerment has become
for the record you know even if this is
a fictional Universe there is actually
nothing empowering about sending
pregnant women off to fight battles a
truly empowered pregnant woman is going
to prioritize protecting her unborn
child and therefore is not going to put
herself in a situation where both she
and the child are very likely to be hurt
but this is this is the Hollywood idea
of empowerment
the empowered person is the person who
acts like anything other than what they
are
the person who rejects their fundamental
duties and responsibilities the
empowered woman is then the woman who
acts like a man while the empowered man
is the man who acts like a woman
this is the empowerment they sell us
which is empowerment turned on its head
it's the opposite of empowerment
which is the essence of wokeness
everything is the opposite of what it
ought to be
and yet
even with all this effort to be woke
film still is not woke enough here's the
headline from Newsweek Avatar faces
calls for boycott over accusations of
racism
the article then explains director James
Cameron is facing allegations of Native
American and Indigenous cultural
appropriation over the themes and
imagery in his latest Blockbuster Avatar
the way of water like his predecessor
the sequel centers on a story about
colonizers taking over land from tribes
and Cameron's telling the colonizers are
humans who need a new and habitable
planet because Earth's resources are
becoming increasingly depleted also like
its predecessor the new Avatar film is
being accused of using an amalgamation
of histories of various indigenous
cultures for a film that features a
largely white cast among those upset by
Cameron's film is you be gay a Native
American influencer and co-chair of
indigenous Pride la
do not watch Avatar the way of water be
gay wrote on Twitter on Sunday join
Natives and other indigenous groups
around the world and boycotting this
horrible and racist film
be gay also said that indigenous
cultures were appropriated in a harmful
manner to satisfy a white man's quote
savior complex another Twitter user
whose critiques of Avatar have gained
attention is Autumn Asher black deer an
assistant professor in The Graduate
School of Social Work at the University
of Denver why watch a movie about blue
aliens when you could just support
actual indigenous people and our
struggle for clean water here on Earth
yes we do exist black deer wrote she
followed up with a thread listing sci-fi
films made by indigenous people
so that's right Avatar commits
appropriation
they do have a point I mean after all
James Cameron
he does cast mostly white actors to
portray people of color in the film now
it's true the color of the people in
this case is blue
and they're not even people but uh
that's irrelevant he could have he could
have at least here's all I'm saying he
could have made the effort to try to
travel to another solar system and find
actual blue aliens to fill these roles
you could have tried didn't even try it
steady just took the easy way out put
actors in blue face instead
now the criticism here is obviously
ridiculous
what's more they're attacking James
Cameron for somehow negating or
minimizing the struggles of quote
indigenous people when the entire movie
is one long overly simplistic childish
retelling of the settlement of the new
world wherein white man bad native
people good
exactly the version of history that
these activists want us to accept they
demand that we accept it
and James Cameron has spent billions of
dollars creating not one but two pieces
of overwrought propaganda to deliver
just that message
and they're still mad
that's how it works
of course the game is rigged especially
if you're a white man
the woker Never Satisfied whatever you
do it will not be enough
whatever you do you should have done
something else
the woke are never happy
they make demands that cannot be
satisfied
that's because they don't want to be
satisfied
they just want the demands they don't
want the satisfaction of those demands
they want the demands
trying to please them then is a Fool's
errand and James Cameron James Cameron
is just that sort of fool which is why
he is canceled for I think like the
second time in a week and that'll do it
for this portion of the show is move
over to the members block hope to see
you there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]